[Studio audience laughing over TV]
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Who are those people?
VISION
What are you wearing?
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Why are they here?
VISION
What are you wearing?
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well, it's our anniversary!
VISION
Our anniversary of what?
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well, if you don't know,
I'm not going to tell you!
JIMMY WOO
Is that...
DARCY LEWIS
Yeah, it looks like her.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
You move at the speed of sound,
and I can make a
pen float through the air.
Who needs to abbreviate?
DARCY LEWIS
Look, I know it's been a crazy few years
on this planet, but he's dead, right?
Not blipped, dead.
VISION
Excellent plan. Where's the tenderizer?
DIRECTOR HAYWARD
What am I looking at?
You? What is this?
Where is this coming from?
DARCY LEWIS
Out there.
AGNES
You didn't answer the back door.
For your upside-down cake.
Oh! Hi, I...
DIRECTOR HAYWARD
Is it authentic?
DARCY LEWIS
I'm not sure how to answer that.
DIRECTOR HAYWARD
Is it happening in real time?
Is it recorded, fabricated?
DARCY LEWIS
I don't know. I don't know.
And I don't know.
DIRECTOR HAYWARD
What do you know?
DARCY LEWIS
My equipment registered an extremely
high level of CMBR. That's...
DIRECTOR HAYWARD
Relic radiation dating back
to the Big Bang.
DARCY LEWIS
Yeah, entwined was a broadcast frequency.
So I had your goons
pick me up a sweet vintage TV.
And when I plug this bad boy in,
voilà, sound and picture.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Dinner is served.
JIMMY WOO
So you're saying the universe created
a sitcom starring two Avengers?
MRS HART
[on TV] European.
DARCY LEWIS
It's a working theory.